he and I had another client who could be
lucid in her dreams which is more common
among women she could ask the damn
characters what they represented and
they would tell her it was like okay
that was pretty weird and like a lot of
the things they told her were really
helpful and they were not things that
she wanted to hear
she she basically one of them told her
she if she was going to live she'd have
to go visit a slaughterhouse and the
reason for that was because she was
raised as a little princess and
protected from horrible mother nature
until she hit puberty in which time she
turned into an evil villain because
that's how the family worked perfect
child
evil teenager overnight and then well
that was hard on her and she wasn't
prepared because she thought the world
was princess world and you know she
couldn't go through a butcher store
without having a fit and no wonder you
know like really Jesus you know it's no
wonder but you do it but she couldn't so
we used to go to butcher stores and that
would make her cry and and that she was
a vegetarian that would make her cry and
you know bemoan the cruelty of the world
it's like you have fair enough man those
are bloody slabs of meat it's like I
don't know why everyone isn't screaming
when they walk through the butcher store
but but you got to get used to it man
because you can't live in the world
otherwise and so the dream character who
was a gypsy told her that she had to go
visit a slaughterhouse which seemed
rather impractical and so I asked her if
she could think of anything else to do
and she thought well why don't we go
visit a funeral home and and watching
him bombing and I thought oh how good
that sounds that sounds like a fun way
to spend a day and so I phoned up a
funeral parlor and I said I had a client
who was terrified of death yeah and I
was a therapist who was also a little
shaky on the concept myself
and so they had no problem with that
they deal with death all the time which
is really something to think about right
a human being can actually have an
occupation where they do nothing but
deal with death and they don't go stark
raving mad it's like what the hell's up
with that it's like working in a
palliative care ward where you're your
clients that you you know have a
relationship all they're going to do is
die this week next week the week after
people do that it's like those people
are tough man they're tough so anyways
we went and watched this embalming which
was I have a rather high level of
disgust sensitivity so it was a little
on the rough side for me but she sat
there and first well she was not look we
were outside this little room she was
not looking at that man
no way and she kind of go like this and
you know that was pretty good and then
she go like this and then she go like
this and then and she watched it and
then she asked if she could go in and
she put on the glove and she touched the
body and she didn't have a fit she
didn't have a panic attack and so she
walked away from there learning that
there's a hell of a lot more to her than
she thought there was and that she could
see things that she didn't think she
could see and live and after that she
sort of had a touchstone it's like well
I'm kind of afraid of this well is it as
bad as going to see the embalming no
it's not that bad
well I guess I can do it it's like an
initiation right she had an initiation
and so did I you know and I learned a
lot from doing that I learned that one
of the things you need to do if you're
going to be a human being is to prepare
yourself to be useful in the face of
death and so when you have a parent that
dies which you know shatters people's
ideas often they can't even think about
it if you can't even think about that
man you've got some thinking to do
because you need to be able to at least
think about that because otherwise
you're just going to be a wasteland when
it happens and you never know you could
even have a higher ambition maybe you
could even be useful when it happens
instead of being part of the heap of
destroyed people who also have to be
taken care of you know and that's brutal
you have to be brutal to be useful
in the aftermath of your parents death
you know you don't get to crumble and
fall apart and no you have every reason
to so you got to be kind of some tough
monster to manage that but you want to
be useful in the face of tragedy or do
you want to be pathetic well you make
your choice